today starts marks the one year since
former police officer derek shovin
murdered george floyd on a minneapolis
street
video of the killing inspired millions
of americans to join mass demonstrations
while others showed their support in the
form of money
big companies like nike apple and target
pledged
millions of dollars to social justice
initiatives
and while donations have since decreased
racial justice leaders hope the giving
will continue
our national correspondent jerica duncan
looks at the impact
of that financial support
[Applause]
in minneapolis and around the world no
justice
protesters enraged by the video of
george floyd's death
and fueled by decades of injustice began
asking
what more can i do in the days and weeks
that followed donations to support civil
rights and black lives poured in
andrea hudson is director of the north
carolina community bail fund of durham
we bail out folks who cannot afford to
pay we get the folks who need it the
most the you know the working class
the poor the homeless who can't afford
to pay a bondsman so they
languish in these cages because they
can't afford it so
the national bail fund network raised 75
million dollars in the two weeks after
floyd's death
we went from bailing out maybe two
to five people a month to bailing out
five to seven people
a week even major corporations took a
stand
black dreams matter black voices matter
black lives matter pledging 1.7
billion dollars to fight racism benevole
a company that processes donations
worldwide since
2008 says at this time last year more
than half of all donations went to
racial justice and equity causes
166 million dollars went to
social justice and racial equity causes
in june that was the most we had
ever seen of any cause category in our
entire history
how is that cause category doing today
now it's back to about five or six
percent of all donations
what does that tell you we're driven to
move when
an issue becomes acute and when it's the
focus
and when it goes back to being normal we
step back into
doing our normal thing which is usually
nothing
why do we respond only to tragedy mark
morial is president and ceo of the
national urban
league he says in 2020 its number of
donors
doubled do you worry that that moment
is not sustainable so i look at it this
way
there's been support but
not at the levels and not at the
magnitude
one necessary to confront
america's most demanding and pressing
problem
and that is the challenges around racial
justice
and as protests continue people like
andrea hudson
press on you got to keep fighting i wish
it was a fight that we didn't have to
fight
because i'm always saying i fight for
freedom because freedom should be free
but since it's not i have to fight for
it for cbs this morning
jerica duncan new york
yeah i like what she said i fight for
freedom because freedom should
be free but i thought marc moriel raised
a really good point why do we only
rise to the occasion during tragedy and
that's what i worry about a year later
we're still having the same conversation
if anything
it's more important now than ever before
that ronald green video that was
released last week
is just as upsetting and just as
damaging and
horrible as george floyd i agree with
you i will say though that that enormous
spike in money that went to social
justice causes
is is extraordinary and i think i would
i would assume say unprecedented i don't
think we've ever seen anything like that
how disheartening to hear that it went
down
yeah well that's i mean that's the way
this country works we focus on something
when it's
when it becomes when it blows up in our
faces man but nobody is going to forget
no impact that george floyd has made on
this country no no and it's obviously
still
having an impact it shows you why it's
so important to press on
in the moment and don't let don't be i
worry about us becoming desensitized
that's what i don't want to happen in
this conversation please don't become
desensitized to this issue it's too
important